it wasn't a runaway hit but the boy was
still one of the strangest mainstream
horror films of 2016
whether you missed out on the first
movie or just need a primer for part two
here's everything you need to know about
brahms the boy - in the boy an American
nanny named Greta is hired by an
eccentric rich family the heel serves
for a very unconventional job they want
her to care for a porcelain doll named
Brahms Hey a jobs a job right the family
gives Greta a very specific set of rules
by which to care for the doll including
talking to him loudly and freezing meals
for him it also turns out that the real
Brahms was the son of the heel shirts
and he was killed in a house fire 20
years ago on his eighth birthday after
one of his young friends was found in
the forest with her skull crushed
suspicious right naturally Greta ignores
the rules at least at first but then the
weird stuff starts piling up Brom
seemingly moves on his own and a child's
voice and sobs can be heard throughout
the mansion skip to the end and Greta
discovers that lo and behold the real
Brahms has been alive and well and he's
now a grown man who's been living in the
walls of the house who walls after the
shocking reveal a tussle ensues and
Greta eventually fights him off and
flees the estate but as we discover
later Brahms is still alive and he's
busy fixing his shattered doll Gretel
might have escaped but it seems that the
Hillshire house might still be housing
Brahms and that he and his doll are out
the torment whoever occupies the mansion
next and Brahms the boy to a young
family will be moving into the Hillshire
mansion with no knowledge of the places
dark history you should google it it's
horrifying when the new family shows up
the young son of the family will find
and befriend the spooky porcelain doll
considering that the first film showed
the heel sirs harboring plans to turn
Greta into a mate for the real Brahms
this spells some pretty terrible things
for this particular young boy who will
be unaware of the malevolent force he
may be inviting into his life director
William Brent fell and screenwriter
Stacy Munir are back for the boys sequel
to finish what they started speaking in
an interview with cosmopolitan the
screenwriter discussed how the first
movie was built around its central twist
that Brahms was in the walls now that
that's out in the open there's no
telling where the story could go as he
put it I think there's a lot of other
interesting stuff you can focus on now
because the audience knows going
what the thing is the lead role in the
first boy movie was played by lauren
cohan of the walking dead but as far as
we know she's not coming back for act
two in her plays former Dawson's Creek
cast member katie holmes as plain liza a
mother who moves into the mansion with
her husband and young son as a real-life
mother to a young daughter holmes didn't
have to dig too deeply to inhabit the
role of a mom terrified for the safety
of her child in June 2019 Holmes told
Entertainment Weekly I felt like this
was the story about a mother and her
child and this evil presence that's
influencing her child and how that's a
universal fear for every parent but
there's also another fear that Holmes
apparently discovered during the making
of the pill dolls those things I'll get
you every time
this is pretty spooky in an interview
with Access Hollywood Holmes stated that
working on the movie was a pretty creepy
experience especially when she was
working one-on-one with the doll and I
loved dolls growing up oh my gosh this
is really ruining dolls for me
rising star Christopher Convery who you
might remember as depicting a young
Billy from stranger things in those
season three flashbacks is playing Jude
the boy who becomes proms new buddy
considering the history of Brahms who
had his childhood taken away from him
it's possible that Jude could be
targeted as part of some scheme for
Brahms to reclaim the childhood he lost
or if the heelshires are somehow still
lurking about it's possible that they
simply want the young boy to replace the
son they hid behind the walls over 20
years ago
either way this kid and his family are
probably in for a bad time composer Bear
McCreary provided an eerie classical
piano score for the first boy movie
giving the story a distinctly vintage
haunting feel for the sequel however a
new composer is stepping up with a job
in the form of musician Brett detter the
musician previously collaborated with
William Bell the director behind Brahms
by composing the nerve grading score for
his 2012 possession movie The Devil
Inside as the solo artist debtor's music
is primarily focused which could impact
the feel of his score it could also
indicate that Brahms the boy too could
have a slightly different vibe and
atmosphere than the first film
originally Brahms the boy too was all
set to be a summer movie with a release
date set for July 2019 then the film was
pushed to December and then February no
official reason behind the delays
was given but it's been speculated the
film was moved to give it space from
other spooky doll films like child's
play and Annabelle comes home the film's
original release date could have also
given the movie direct competition from
other horror movies such as crawl and
ready or not no such concerns at the
start of the year now scheduled for
February 21st the film's new release
slot will put the boy up against birds
of prey
Sonic the Hedgehog and Vin Diesel's
bloodshot so if you run a horror mood
that weekend your only option is lurking
somewhere in the walls check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff or coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]